[Music]
now here you can hear the Adhan nice and
clear al hamdulillah
[Music]
I testify that there is nothing worthy
of worship except Allah the Creator and
I bear witness I testify that Muhammad
peace and blessing be a plan is the
messenger
[Music]
[Music]
come to prayer come to prayer come to
success come to success
[Music]
assalamualaikum for all brothers at the
states
you are welcome in Bosnia big Salam was
the beautiful country and everybody's
welcome everybody yes come come
[Music]
[Music]
so what do we have here we got we'll be
walking around yeah Karla's good she she
can wear one of my favorite places to be
away from the city out in the nature a
beautiful farm here so I wanna get
little hung over loosely just so much
baby those good feel smell the farms
horses here is the milking station here
[Music]
because dear Buster we don't have the
system where you can track genetics and
pedigree or for lending me the most with
pedigree so that means they're
genetically pure breeds pure breed so
you can expect malformations for bigger
furnish a litter here he asked about
what happens when it gets extremely cold
what are you saying what kind of chance
is that look look how the almighty set
it up where they start what happens we
start to grow eat more and grow more
specific hair to endure the cold cold
Allah says Allah the Almighty said there
and that system in place
[Music]
you know what interesting thing these
are the females now look at the male
here what do you see if you could strike
the difference so this is the meal huh
look look he's got a beard the males got
a beard so this is a truly organic apple
yeah so there's a while saying a man
said look I don't I don't eat an apple
with a worm wouldn't eat this is in the
United States the United States the corn
is 80% or more GMO non-gmo corn is the
real corn here here real Tomatoes real
corny see that food want to be real
healthy eat real food
getting ready to have a nice meal look
oh we got some good peppers chemical
pesticide free potatoes these are not
bottles of wine what rosemary made from
no sugar enough to be just hundred
percent beer what kind of despair juice
we got honey oh so amazing beautiful is
a must you this is a must
look at that view
this is where we take a time out work
done yeah and we come to say God is the
greatest
we give thanks gratitude recharge their
shoe body father's even say Tallis
schmuck Oh
so Tom [ __ ] Ameena [ __ ] Alice a schmuck
Oh God
[Music]
uh-huh
oh [ __ ] come here
McDonagh r0j style oh Christ the
one-story Chester
and dollarsí
[Music]
rasca be down huh know what [ __ ] Camila
Cosway Hamza is blooming are who you see
Yas some rope chain
yeah says of em Edley Hamza is play
Menace re our stoles a Luba
[Music]
[Music]
merly
Oh